the honeymoon stand-up special is what I
want to ask you about where the title
come from oh so my husband and I will
survive this show another period and it
takes place in new poll you love the
show it's a very funny idea it's a
reality show that's like Downton Abbey
but like meets the Kardashians and it
takes place in the Gilded Age and so we
would go to Newport and tour these
houses and learn about all these rich
people at the turn of the century and
there was this couple who were so rich
they got married and then went on a
ten-year honeymoon Wow so I've been
basically trying to recreate that in my
life
so you emotion trying to recreate the
the basically this long honeymoon yeah
and so now we have a special of our tour
so our tour we would go to all these
honeymoon destinations like Palm Springs
and Napa and for some reason Albuquerque
I don't know why that happened and yeah
it was it was really really fun and okay
and do you I'm just curious how did how
did your proposal go like how did your
kind of motion propose to you
oh well we were at this restaurant we
were in New Orleans my favorite city and
we were at this restaurant and he kept
asking to move tables you know and he's
Jewish so I thought maybe there was a
draft and
because they're always uncomfortable yes
and so we moved like three times and
then finally it was like what's going on
and he's like nothing nothing I was
really nervous he didn't ask me I was
because he can ask me to marry him and
then we ended up walking after dinner to
the Mississippi River and then just
where it ended he just was finally like
I think he was so nervous he just kind
of pulled out this ring and put it on my
middle finger and it was just like your
middle thing you didn't understand what
happened and then he wouldn't and I was
like aren't you gonna kneel he's like no
Jews don't kneel I guess that's the
thing I didn't know that I didn't either
okay made it up I think he's making up a
lot of stuff we gotta move tables why
I'm a Jew I can't have hot sauce I'm a
Jew all right I just randomly got one
huh
okay the honeymoon stand-up special is
available now and it's on Netflix
I'm so happy for you this is your first
child right yes only child last five
okay never again she's cute though yeah
all right Natasha Leggero
congratulations
[Applause]
you